[Music]
[Music]
a couple of weekends ago i was playing
through the third and final title update
15 pts i missed the second one so i was
wanting to see some of the changes that
had been implemented for the countdown
game mode but also wanted to try out
some of the new gear
the devs had announced that there were
some issues with some of the pieces that
were causing some disconnects and deltas
so these have been removed but given
that i was having nothing but delta
issues unable to even finish a single
countdown session i thought i'd have a
bit of a muck around with them anyway
i've seen the hundreds of videos coming
out about the pts builds weapons and
every small change and tweet coming from
the developers so don't worry this won't
just be another one of those
this video will be a little bit
different i'm actually not quite sure
what to make of it to be honest and i'm
hoping you may be able to help some of
you may remember seeing a video i put
out a while ago called named and exotic
items story slash law
this was a summary of a number of items
available in-game that had a bit of
background and story that most people
would overlook when playing through for
example the white death named marksman
rifle pays homage to simu hayaha a
finnish military sniper in the winter
war who was believed to have killed over
500 men he went on to live up until the
ripe old age of 96 despite having half
his face blown off by a red army
explosive round
i'll chuck that video in the top right
corner if you wanted to check it out
so this will be a video similar to that
where i will go over the lore of some of
the new weapons and gear being
introduced in title update 15.
much like the existing named and exotic
items i haven't found everything or
figured out what they mean and some
don't have anything at all but for now
we'll be covering the catharsis exotic
mask king breaker named assault rifle
and deer named lmg
the catharsis is a new exotic mask being
introduced in title update 15. the
talent vicious cycle looks like an
interesting one that i can see myself
trying out on a tank build to provide
extra team support but this isn't what
i'm interested in here
if we look to the top there is a quote
that reads the establishment does
everything in its power to ensure that
the revolutionary rage is redirected
into empty outlets which provide
pressure releases for desires that could
become dangerous if allowed to progress
going back to the talent there is a
direct relation here where if i sum it
up in its most simple form the more
damage you take the more stacks and
power you obtain when a limit is reached
a cloud of healing is released purging
all status effects restoring armor to
you and those around you
this quote actually originates from a
book written by george l jackson called
blood in my eye
jackson was an american activist of
unbridled depression and racism
even while behind bars he was involved
in revolutionary activity taking a stand
at a time where the system was doing all
that it could to break his spirit
blood in my eye ties together a
collection of jackson's letters and
essays in which he presents his analysis
of armed struggle class war fascism
communism and a wide range of other
topics
it was completed only days before
jackson was killed by prison guards in
1971 during an alleged escape attempt
the quote used on the catharsis is only
a snippet of a much larger quote
fascism has established itself in a most
disguised and efficient manner in this
country it feels so secure that the
leaders allow us the luxury of a faint
protest
take the protests too far however and
they will show their other face
doors will be kicked down in the night
and machine gun fire and buckshot will
become the medium of exchange
the establishment does everything in its
power to ensure that revolutionary rage
is redirected into empty outlets which
provide pressure releases for desires
that could become dangerous if allowed
to progress
one has to understand that the fascist
arrangement tolerates the existence of
no valid revolutionary activity it is
programmed into its very nature a
massive complex and automatic defense
mechanism for all of our old methods for
raising the consciousness of a
potentially revolutionary class of
people
the essence of a usa totalitarian social
political capitalism is concealed behind
the illusion of a mass-participatory
society
we must rip away its mask then the
debate can end and we can enter a new
phase of struggle based on the
development of an armed revolutionary
culture that will triumph
this certainly sounds familiar when
referring to the division story but more
on this later
the king breaker is a new named assault
rifle as per all named items it provides
the perfect or fully optimized version
of a talent available on other items
in this case it's flatline with a
perfect version of his 20 amplified
weapon damage to pulsed enemies and
after two kills pulse is applied to the
next enemy that is hit
the quote on kingbreaker is the limits
of tyrants are prescribed by the
endurance of those whom they oppress
while i don't see any obvious relation
to the talent this quote comes from an
individual named frederick douglass
douglas was born in 1817 and after
escaping from slavery he would become
the leading african-american voice of
the 19th century
although douglas has been called the
father of the civil rights movement he
also assisted in shaping the american
nation as a woman's right activist
public speaker author journalist
publisher and social reformer
committed to freedom douglas dedicated
his life to achieving justice for all
americans in particular african
americans women and minority groups
he envisioned america as an inclusive
nation strengthened by diversity and
free of discrimination
douglas also served as an advisor to
presidents where abraham lincoln would
refer to him as the most meritorious man
of the 19th century
analyzing the quote on the king's lair
this could be considered a direct call
to action and while at the time this was
considered as a reference to slavery
there are many other issues douglas
supplied the same statement to
this is a warning not to accept make jew
and suffer tyranny lightly that by doing
so we put our own freedom at risk of
being harmed or destroyed
deer is a new name to lmg this is pretty
much the lmg version of the kingslayer
coming with the perfect flatline talent
along with a number of other items this
is showing that the developers are
looking to prop up the pulse skills
going forward these have perhaps been
underutilized across builds up until now
but this isn't the only similarity
across the two weapons
on the quote this weapon reads
if you dare to struggle you dare to win
if you dare not to struggle then damn it
you don't deserve to win
this follows the similar meaning behind
the king slayer quote where the message
is that you should fight for what you
believe in
much like the other two this quote comes
from american activist fred hampton
born in 1948 he would eventually become
the deputy chairman of the national
black panther party and chair of the
illinois chapter
hampton founded the anti-racist
anti-class rainbow coalition a prominent
multicultural political organization
that initially included the black
panthers young patriots poor whites and
the young lords hispanics and an
alliance among major chicago street
gangs to help end infighting and work
for social change
hampton considered fascism the greatest
threat
saying nothing is more important than
stopping fascism because fascism will
stop us all
he would eventually be killed in 1969 by
chicago police in a raid that saw more
than 90 bullets fired into the apartment
containing hampton his pregnant fiancee
and several other black panthers who
were sleeping
upon finding that hampton was still
alive he was executed by an officer at
close range who fired two bullets into
his head
while at this point it probably sounds
like i'm attempting to initiate some
sort of revolution i assure you that
this is not the case i'm waiting until i
have a much larger following before
going down that path but the origin of
these quotes all talk to similar aspects
fascist totalitarian and class-based
rule of which we have seen many examples
throughout history like benito mussolini
and adolf hitler and while ubisoft has
publicly stated in the past that their
games aren't political it can
understandably be a challenge to create
any sort of more grounded semi-realistic
good versus evil storyline without
intentionally or unintentionally having
some sort of association to events and
regimes that have happened in the past
or present
plus it doesn't help that people like
myself take enjoyment out of making
these sorts of games even more immersive
by attempting to close the gap between
fiction and reality
the division story has certainly been
leading us down a path of fascist
totalitarian and class-based rule with
the unknown employers behind natalia and
the black tusk attempting to gain
control over the united states of
america
but this is where i raised the question
to you
are these references simply just a nod
in the direction of prominent figures in
the american civil rights movement
or are these put in place to speak of
the similar and i use that word very
loosely situation that is playing out in
the division story
let me know what you think in the
comments
these are the type of topics that i love
coming across in games any excuse to
research real world history and attempt
to find ties within the story but as
always i could be completely over
analyzing something that has merely been
put into the game as just a powerful
thought-provoking quote to add some
filler in an area where perhaps no depth
was ever intended to be
placed anyway thank you very much for
watching and i'll catch in the next one
cheers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign